حتى الان الاجراءات ايضا تثير عديد
الاسئله نقلا عن مراسلتنا الشرطه
الاسرائيليه تدفع بقوات كبيره بينها قوات
خاصه الى رعنانا هذا الاجراء متى يتخذ
عاده في
اسرائيل هذا الاجراء يتخذ عاده فقط اذا
هنالك حادث امني يعني يعني في تاكيد على
ان هنالك حادث امني وقد يكون انه هنالك في
اخرين كانوا بالسياره واستطاعوا الهرب
فالبحث عنهم ولكن حتى الان من لمعلومات
التي لدينا لا يوجد اي تاكيد او اي حتى
حديث في هذا الاتجاه ولذلك الشرطه على ما
يبدو تتخذ اجراءات اوتوماتيكيه دون ان
يكون لها اي معلومات في في الواقع ولذلك
هنا يعني من جديد انا اؤكد هذه الفوضه
التي تعيشها القياده هنا في هذه المرحله
قياده الشرطه في هذا المكان بالذات ولو
حصل هذا الحادث في مكان اخر لوجدت نفس
الفوضى موجوده بسبب الوضع الذي تعيش شه
القياده الاسرائيليه في كل مستوياتها فوضى
عارمه وهذه الفوضه تجلت الان في هذا
الحادث الذي امام بالحديث عن الفوضى نذكر
سابقا بانه في مناطق في الضفه الغربيه
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قتلت مواطنا
اسرائيليا لانها اشتبهت فيه رغم انه كان
يحذرهم وينبههم بانه اسرائيلي والسؤال هنا
عن هذا الارتباك يعني ذكرت الامر من باب
المثال على ما ذكرته انت سيد يزبك فالسؤال
هنا عن ا يفترض من يقوم ب
ب الخروج من هذه الحاله من الفوضى هناك
تحقيق اولي اذا سمحت لي للشرطه
الاسرائيليه شخص طعن امراه واستولى على
مركبتها ثم دهس اخرين في اكثر من موقع هذا
اخر خبر عاجل سيد يزبك تحقيق اولي للشرطه
الاسرائيليه شخص لم تحدد طعن امراه
واستولى على مركبتها ثم دهس اخرين في اكثر
من موقع بناء على هذا المعطى هل يمكن
ترجيح ما الذي حدث حتى الان ا حتى بعد
مرور تقريبا ساعه الامور غير واضحه بشكل
كامل يعني قد يمكن ان يكون هذا الحادث مثل
ما تفضلت حضرتك وهذا التحقيق الاول لشرطه
ولكن السؤال الذي يسال اذا كانت الشرطه
لديه هذه المعلومات ولماذا ت تخرج قوه في
شوارع المدينه ويعني كانه هنالك في تحييد
وغير تحييد لشخص وفي كانه يعني اعمال اي
امنيه كبيره يعني وخلق نوع من الرعب
والهلع يعني الشارع الاسرائيلي لا ينقصه
رعب وهلع والان بتصرف الشرطه هذا عمليا
يخلق نوعا من الهلع والرعب في في الشارع
وهذا يعني قد ينعكس الرعب التي يعني من
يسمع الاخبار في تل ابيب او في اي مكان
اخر يعني قد يؤدي الى حوادث اخرى لانه كل
من يشتبه بشيء من بين المواطنين الذين
المسلحين يقوم باستعمال سلاحه فهنا
اشكاليه كبيره جدا وهذا ما حضرنا منه منذ
البدايه يعني الكثير من الذين كتبوا في
هذا الموضوع وانا من بينهم حضر انه هذا
السلاح الذي موجود الان بين ايدي الناس
بسبب الاوضاع الخطره قد يستعمل ضد الناس
العاديين ضد المواطنين العاديين لانه كل
واحد يعني قد يفسر سبب استعماله للسلاح ان
هو شعر بخطر من مواطن فلان او من مواطن
علان بانه هذا المواطن هو يقون بعمل كل
ذلك القناه الانيه الاسرائيليه تنقل عن
رئيس بلديه رعنانا الحدث مستمر ولم ينتهي
بعد دون توضيح ما هو الحدث
المستمر وتفاصيل اخرى والسؤال مره اخرى عن
حاله الفوضى في المعلومات اعود اليك رئيس
البلديه يتحدث الشرطه تتحدث وسائل الاعلام
تتحدث ما الذي
يحدث ه يعني اكثر من هذا المثال للفوضى
اين الشرطه يجب ان يكون متحدث واحد وهو
الشرطه التي تتحدث في هذا الموضوع لانه
هذه قضيه
تثير الامن ولذلك كل واحد لديه يعني يدلي
بدلوه هنا هل القضيه هي قضيه تصريحات من
هذا الطرف وم ذك الطرف ليخلق بلبله بين
الناس من المفروض لو في نظام وتنظيم
والمجتمع منظم والقياده منظمه ان يخرج
المتحدث باسم الشرطه ويتحدث واحد اين
ثلاثه وينهي القضيه انما ياتي رئيس
البلديه كل دقيقه ويتحدث و وكانه هو قائد
عام يعني يعني هنا في خلط بين اصحاب
الوضائف افترض سيد زبك بان هذا الحديث
وهنا نذكر بالخبر العاجل الذي نقلناه قبل
قليل عن القناه الثانيه الاسرائيليه رئيس
بلديه رعنانا يقول الحدث مستمر ولم ينتهي
بعد انت تعتقد بان هذا ليس من مسؤولياته
ويفترض ان يكون من جهه اعلى
الشرطه نعم واضح يعني حته يعني المصطلح
انه الحدث مستمر هو يعني كلام امني ومن
ومن يستطيع ان يجلي بهذا الكلام يجب ان
تكون مسؤوله مسؤوليه امنيه او صاحب وظيفه
امنيه رفيعه يعني وهو المتحدث باسم الشرطه
هو الذي يتحدث في هذه المواضيع وهي محدده
حسب حتى
يعني الاعراف المتعامل بها وليس ان يقوم
رئيس بلديه اي بلديه كانت تكون بالتحدث
مكان الشرطه الا اذا كانت الشرطه غائبه
الا اذا كان متحدث الشرطه غير موجود مخفي
فهذا يعني من جديد يدل على الوضع الغير
مستقر الذي يعيشها المجتمع والمؤسسات ليس
فقط الناس وكذلك المؤسسات تعيش يعني وضع
حقيقه استثنائي انا استعمل الان كلمه
استثنائي بهذا الوضع الفوضوي الموجود في
داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي نعم